[Music]
it was a wild week in the nfl and you
know the ramifications that is going to
have on the nfl draft and that's why we
are here live in the bleacher report app
every thursday at 1pm eastern time i'm
connor rogers the lead nfl draft analyst
here at bleacher report and with me
every single week is the college
football analyst from stadium michael
felder and a special guest this week
from the athletic football show nate
tice belder i'll start with you man this
has been we went from combine to
quarterback trade mania how are we
feeling right now we got a loaded
rundown today
yeah man this is one of those things
that like makes you realize kind of the
unique
situation that we're in with respect to
the nfl in the nfl draft because
it doesn't matter what rankings nate
puts up what rankings conor puts up if
they're going to decide to trade guys
around move pieces it doesn't matter
what your mock draft looks like so i i
you guys are at the combine so i'm going
to kind of run traffic on this one but
man like let's get into it with russell
wilson nate like
dude
how does that change everything
i know it's a year-round league now i
mean that's this is just what it is it's
uh and especially with the now going to
week 18 and we just we go super bowl
deep breath okay right into the combine
now right to trades right now right into
free agency but with the russell wilson
stuff i mean it's kind of it's crazy
you're never going to feel good about
trading a star quarterback or a an elite
what we call an elite quarterback
because it's just like the nba it's like
that's what you're trying to get in the
league it is a star at that position
that's what you treat it as so no matter
what the seahawks got back it was never
going to feel enough but what the
seahawks are batting is does russell
wilson you know his athleticism wanes a
little bit he's playing in a tough
division maybe we get lucky in that
regard but this is crazy russell goes
into the afc west it's a freaking
bloodbath
in that division now it's absolutely
ridiculous so it's gonna be very very
interesting to see what that new dynamic
what the new broncos team is and all
that and the repercussions what happens
with the seahawks as well
so connor yeah i think when you look at
the broncos what are the what do they do
what do the seahawks do with pick nine
i mean when you look at the seattle team
you go from not having that first round
pick right because of the jamal adams
trade and now you're inserted into the
top ten now obviously they are preparing
like they always do even not having that
first rounder all year where those
evaluations are filing in now this is a
team that needs to accept that they are
in a full rebuild right they could p
carroll is the oldest coach in the nfl
so he has to answer the question is
there a quarterback worth taking in that
top 10 that we are going to reset our
franchise with but he would be walking
into a roster that quite frankly isn't
very good right now or are we going to
do this slow are we going to rebuild our
trenches our offensive line isn't very
talented we still need a top flight pass
rusher on the other side of the ball you
can get those things with the ninth
overall pick and then you can look for
your quarterback a lot of fans don't
like to hear this but you can kick that
can down the road to 2023 because this
is going to be a true rebuild i wonder
if they take calls on dk metcalf as well
rather than paying him but if they do
pay him then he's there for the long
haul with whoever that young quarterback
is so seattle can go a lot of different
directions they are inserted right into
the important factor of this draft while
the broncos they go to rams win now mode
see i'm and i'm curious to see is pete
carroll going to be there for all of
this that's going to be an interesting
part let's get to another one though
let's get to carson wentz right go into
the commander's from indianapolis and i
think this one and connor i'll kick this
one off with you
it's more than just what you do on the
field like obviously they were on the
field issues with respect to carson once
but also it just kind of seemed like
they didn't like him so
what do you do if you're the cults and
what do you do like you're the
commanders now you're out of the
quarterback market
yeah i think for carson wentz it's not
the best sign that you were acquired for
a first round pick last year and you had
a mega money contract and then you're
moved after one year and this is you
know chris ballard at the podium at the
combine the gm of the colts did not say
anything to inspire confidence in the
carson wentz future in indianapolis so
the trade isn't too shocking i think the
return is actually shockingly good for
the cults
getting the two third round picks back
the swap of the second rounders and
offloading all that 2022 money now they
are a team that needs to get creative to
find a way what their future quarterback
looks like i've heard that they are all
over this quarterback class that they've
done a lot of work on kenny pickett but
they are not in range to select him
right now can you bundle 42 can you
bundle a couple of third rounders and
find your way into the middle of the
first round obviously with more assets
included in that trade maybe a player
that's what the colts are trying to
figure out right now they could look for
the old stop gap option and jimmy
garoppolo although i don't think that
will inspire a lot of confidence in
colts fans for the long term future and
then the big second thing here the
second layer here guys is
washington was picking at 11. there's a
good chance they had a shot at any
quarterback they wanted in this class
and instead they traded
valuable assets in cap space for carson
wentz i think the most disrespected
aspect of this entire trade is the 2022
quarterback class
i it's not a mistake this happened after
the combine
that everyone finally got to meet these
guys and see these guys like
maybe we should uh start calling some
teams instead of waiting for the draft
well i'll tell you what here we go i'll
call i'll time it out let's do this
let's get into the combine you know what
let's do it right you guys are at the
combine you guys watched the combine we
did the whole deal obviously oh by the
way aaron rodgers signs a 200 million
contract 157 million dollars guaranteed
so guess what man he's not going to be
there to ruin jeopardy for me thank you
um but the reality of it is for me when
we look at these quarterbacks and you
you mentioned that nate coming out of
the combine so did the rankings for you
change for these guys coming out of the
combine who showed themselves off who
looked good like what do you think about
that as we show the aaron rodgers deal
here what do you think about these guys
coming out of the combine because as you
alluded to
teams were
sort of less than impressed with the
group as a
whole yeah i you know the
how i kind of thought he would run so
maybe that bump isn't as like as drastic
as maybe for maybe some other people um
i think what what uh willis malik willis
did
interview and showed that maybe that
offense that he ran wasn't because of
him it was just hugh freeze running his
stuff and then that's what he just had
to run that offense is that a can't or
won't kind of thing that these teams
have to figure out and from what i got
from what i gathered i wasn't sitting in
those team interviews talking with malik
willis but for when i gathered that he
did really really well and that's more
than anything he could have done you're
throwing on air i could go out tomorrow
and throw on air you know so we we want
to make a big deal about those types of
things but really it's but that
interview process i've heard that you
did an awesome job which is good and
that's what teams wanted to see so i
think now it's more people gotta comfort
okay okay maybe we can really work with
this and make it he could be a true
project for us at the next level
i think what uh ritter was the other
you got to show off his confidence and
show off obviously during the games he
shows off his confidence but even when
they asked him hey why are you doing all
the testing and he was like because i'm
good at it like and it's like
i like that answer like all right that's
that's frank i get it you have some
confidence with it so i think those two
more than anybody really helped and
showed maybe create a little bit of a
upward swing as put
steady or took a drop down maybe even
after they talk to teams
all right before we get into the
quarterback class as a whole let's dive
into the comment section that is firing
off in the bleacher report app live
right now i'll read a couple funny ones
before we get to the questions uh c
mccullough bye bye wentz mkent93 colts
are absolutely screwed now not many
quarterbacks are going to fit there and
then i'll throw the first one here i'll
start with you nate
joeystory13 said do you think the chiefs
make a big move now that the broncos
acquired russ
i think the chiefs for the next decade
are all in no matter what they can
always borrow from the bank of patrick
mahomes uh i think that's what that's
just the world they're gonna be living
in so i think their strategy didn't
change i think they were gonna be taking
swings at guys anyways uh i think they
maybe get a bigger receiver than maybe
we even anticipated um and i also think
defensively there's a couple guys they
might get creative with and try to bring
in um but i i think it hasn't really
changed
makes more sense they can argue it even
more about like really pushing their
chips into the middle
all right felder i'll throw this one
your way and then you could take us home
into this entire quarterback class from
the combine mkent93 says
do the broncos even make the playoffs
now let's not forget the playoffs are
expanded now so the chances should be
pretty good you think russ is enough to
get that offense and roster over the
hump
man
it's it's going to be tough for them
like the reality of it is is is
like
a quarterback like a quarterback can do
a lot but it doesn't rust doesn't strike
me as a quarterback that does everything
for his team he's not patchma patrick
mahomes right he's not aaron rodgers
he's a different type of quarterback
he's still incredibly good but i don't
think he's the guy that without a super
high quality defense without a
remarkable
ability to turn teams over i don't think
he's the guy that does that so i think
that they've got to use this draft
they've got to use you know the upcoming
years to find ways to put pieces around
him so that he can do what he does which
is an exceptional job of
creating plays down the field so that
you have those explosive plays while
also making sure that he minimizes the
negative plays
all right i love it felder all right
moving on here we are gonna look at this
quarterback class as a whole we are
coming out of the combine obviously and
there wasn't a lot going on with this
quarterback class at the nfl combine to
be fair but behind the scenes a lot
happened so felder what do you want to
start with here coming out of indy
i mean come on dude we're gonna we're
we're gonna do it let's go ahead let's
go ahead and do it
the biggest news for the quarterback
class
was the eight and a half inch hands of
kenny pickett right that's what we're
talking about
now if you look at me obviously my
thumb's a little past there so i got a
little bit more going on but i thought
that was honestly with the exception of
malik willis deep ball am i crazy to
think that can he pick its hand size and
nate i'll kick it to you as a former
quarterback like
that felt crazy that that was the
biggest news of the of the weekend for
quarterbacks
i think it's easy to grasp for people so
they can do what you just did hey let's
pull out a tape measure what how big is
my hand like i think if it was a huge
issue in college i would make a bigger
deal about it if he was fumbling three
times a game i would be like okay well
now we have an easy explanation for it
he really wasn't it's more of the
weather thing that's going to be maybe a
question mark but he already has his
answer he wears gloves it's not a he
already has tried to figure out what
that quote unquote problem is so yes is
it something is it make him
do you want to see that no absolutely
not you'd rather have monster gigantic
hands and never have to have to worry
about that but it's still something that
you're taking consideration but it's not
the end-all be-all i think it's not
dante culpepper's situation
well here's the thing and i want to go
to conor on this because connor you saw
him at the seat you saw him at the
senior bowl and i know we got to get to
malik willis but
connor you saw him what was it like for
him when we did see weather him and then
you take us into malik willis who you
saw kind of the juxtaposition of those
guys playing in weather
yeah it was an issue i mean there's just
no way to sugarcoat it right i do i do
agree with nate that on the college tape
there's not it's not like every game
you're writing down okay the small hands
are showing up whether it is obviously
the grip strength he's not fumbling left
and right like daniel jones has in the
nfl it's not on that kind of level i
think it's just a matter of what i found
fascinating was that monsoon day where i
didn't think it would be easy for any
quarterback to throw
specifically ritter and kenny pickett
could not get anything going it was bad
handlings of snaps it was misplaced
throws all over the place a lot of
quarterbacks would struggle in that
environment but on the flip side malik
willis thrived malik willis had his best
day throwing in that monsoon it did not
affect him so i think it speaks to
the grip strength the overall arm talent
and once again a lot of it was throwing
against air but it's still something
that stood out to me where if you're
malik willis coming out of liberty uh
you do have a long ways to go but all
these quarterbacks do this was a way to
gain an edge in this quarterback class
and i think since the season ended and
we've gone through the all-star game
process the combine process and
obviously now we're going through pro
days malik willis has thrived and
started to take a little bit of a lead
in this quarterback class
i i love malik willis i think he's
remarkable i love the i mean he there's
a play against virginia tech where he
evades the rush
rolls back out throws it and throws it
on a rope hits the guy you know at the
one yard line right there going towards
out of bounds away from the defender i
think he's got great ball placement um
uh nate when you look at malik willis
we've already hit on ritter so when you
talk about malik willis his down the
field throws do you think that that gets
him into the first quarterback off the
board zone i had to pick it ahead of
ritter
i i think it does i think i came i've
come around on on willis i i i'm staying
safe with him i have like my second
round great on him but i understand the
home run swing that he is that what in
this in the nfl the level of competence
has raised for everybody like the
average like you know the replacement
level has raised the bar has risen but
that you still need that guy that can
create that guy that as i would say is
go get a bucket for you and that's what
malik willis is that's the appeal of him
he's that home run swing so i've kind of
come around going like well he's risky
he's you know he's got a lot he's got
really learned the nfl speed and
learning nfl offenses but guess what if
he hits that's the home run swing you're
taking and isn't that the whole point of
trying to find one of these guys
especially in the first
so that
yeah
i at first was like oh man he doesn't
really have that you know true
quarterback to him but now i look at him
i'm like but he has the traits that the
top guys have and that's what you're
going for so and that's why i think he
has i think now there's a gap between
him and everybody else as far as how
teams consider him how we are talking
about him i think all of us have figured
out it's like that's what you're trying
to do in the draft right that you're
trying to find one of these guys that
can truly carry your team and he has
that appeal to him
so i want to get this one in real quick
i'm going to go i'm going to conor nate
you come in right after conor but i want
to hear about desmond ritter because
nate you mentioned earlier in the show
that ritter seemed to be become the
number two guy who had a picket uh what
what offense what scheme what teams does
he fit with because we know it's now
what cults seahawks bucks steelers all
teams that are in the the buyers market
when it comes to quarterback where can
he fit uh and start with connor where
can desmond ritter fit as a for a team
if they expect him to come in and make
some plays early
yeah it's going to be fascinating and i
don't know if that's what you want from
ritter although i think out of all of
these guys he actually might be the one
that besides pickett you're most
confident in playing from day one
because he's the four-year starter of
the group right now what i would like to
see from ritter despite being a
four-year starter i felt like over time
his actual play speed
never got drastically better i think
that's something that can improve and
you can see signs of that even this year
you know there's a big gap he had eight
passes batted at the line of scrimmage
there's times where the defensive line
can see where he's going i think he gave
safeties a decent amount of time to get
to the ball make a play on his throws
like all of these guys he can throw with
more anticipation but ritter's not going
to go before pickett or malik willis
which makes you wonder
will a team like the bucks at the end of
round one will they roll with trask and
a veteran or will they look at a young
quarterback like ritter did we get into
the round two territory are the lions
gonna look at this quarterback class but
not at the top they'd rather look at it
with like pick 34. that's a spot for
ritter where we know goff's gonna play
this year but you can see a scenario
where ritter comes in some point during
the season yes the texans are rolling
with davis mills but maybe they actually
want competition at their quarterback
spot they come back around again at 37.
so i think when you're looking at
desmond ritter for me he's not going to
be he's not better than willis he's not
better than pickett i wouldn't take him
in the first round but i absolutely see
a scenario where he goes in the top 50
and gets a chance to start at the nfl
level this year
yeah and i i think that's i think that's
fair
i mean it's that's where it's so funny
about this class is i i'm higher on
ritter than conor is but that's the
thing is he would have been qb5 in last
year's draft like
it's it's that he is in that like i
don't have him above like a late first
round grade that's just more talking
about the class too and i think what
you're just saying right there with the
lions at the end the first like that's
actually like a perfect kind of little
spot for him value-wise how i look at
him what he can step in and do for you
like moving up uh uh the colts packaging
their picks getting the second round the
seat we'll see what the seahawks do but
like you know seahawks in this early
second round if they don't want to go
with one i pick nine you know willis
might be gone by then i mean just
hearing kind of the the smoke rising
about will is coming after the combine
it just really seems like he's going
higher and higher higher than
again uh maybe a team like the falcons
early in the second um those are kind of
teams i can see them really going like a
team that
is they're trying to find that next guy
so but what's nice about ritter is you
can have a guy already in place or if
you need a guy day one he could step in
and be competent for you or like in
theory anyways that's the like you said
conor he's the four-year starter so like
the image that you have in your head is
like okay this guy can at least handle
an offense um so i just think that's
what's nice about ritter he appeals to a
lot of different teams but a team any of
those teams look in the 20s in the early
second round i think that's really that
range that he goes and there's some
interesting teams that bucks team
i'd much rather have ritter than kyle
trask especially with what bruce arians
wants to do and trying to push all those
deep balls down the field i don't know
if that's kyle trask's game
as much as i like trask but it's i think
that's more of a ritter kind of thing
all right so i'm going to get in here i
i'm going to go real quick because
connor you got to say i know you got to
take us to the comments so nate give me
three sentences on sam howe because i'm
a unc guy okay so give me three
sentences on sam howell and then conor
you follow it up and then you take us to
the comments
all right beautiful deep ball
tough as hell and his teammates love him
so that sentence two
cannot read anything in between the
hashes those are my three settings
that's my that that's my breakdown on
how tough you love his style play
because you can tell he pumps up the
teammates he throws awesome default but
then
trying to actually progress and read out
plays it's it's sketchy and uh makes you
very worried about what he'll do at the
next level
yeah i was telling you guys on our call
for this show that when you watched sam
howell play over the years and i thought
he displayed more ability as a runner
this year when there was less talent
around him and he had to make plays with
his legs when guys aren't open or like
nate said he's just not seeing it
sometimes there's good running and
sometimes there's running because you're
not falling into line as a passer it
just reminds me of case keenum and a lot
of fans listening to this will not love
to hear that about a quarterback
prospect but you have to realize with
case keenum he has been a guy that can
give you a flash spot start inject some
life into an offense with plays broken
down but he's never going to be this 17
game top 12 kind of starter in the
league that's constantly playing within
structures so i think for sam howell he
came into the season with a lot of early
round one expectations and that's kind
of fallen to mid-round two as a
long-term backup with the ability to be
a spot starter in short spurts all right
let's dive into the comments mcat 93 is
back says kenny pickett is way overrated
at jojo 4734 says who's a quarterback
you could see slipping further than
projected nate i'll throw that one to
you is there a guy that we've heard a
lot about in this class that might be
not even first round getting top 50 love
that you think ends up falling
well corrupt matt corral and i think
it's just maybe some of the injury he
weighed in a little bit more but i think
it's just more circumstances maybe teams
going up
her guy and i'm not saying going into
the fourth round or anything like that
but maybe that late second early third
which is different than maybe the late
first that he's been projected as uh
originally um another guy that maybe um
got bumped down a little bit and just
maybe because arm strength was bailly
zappy and as much as i like him but
that's more of like he might drop to
like the third to the fifth you know
nothing crazy in that regard but just
maybe you see when you watch malik
willows throw a beautiful deep ball off
the screen at the combine and then you
see bailey's zappy throwing a deep ball
and it ends up 10 yards short you're
kind of going ah that's right that's the
difference
but i would say those two i'll top my
head
all right felder i'll throw this last
one to you and then you can take us to
combine risers this is from
jerr8l said
what's the best quality
in the best quarterback this draft i
know you had some praise from malik
willis earlier in this show
let's hear it yeah i mean listen nate
hit on sam house deep ball i think we
talked about malik willis deep ball i'll
be honest i think it's kenny pickett and
playing in a mark whipple offense i i
think that
that's gonna be something that's gonna
bump him up and remember this in the nfl
draft it just takes one team that's all
i think all you need is one team to like
some quality about you and i think one
of the qualities that teams are going to
value highly is the fact that he did
play in an offensive system that was ran
by multiple nfl teams under a guy like
mark whipple so i think that that's
probably going to be the most coveted
the most
interesting how you handle it trait is
the fact that he did play an offense ran
by a guy who i don't know won some nfl
football games with him with his
offenses you know so uh
am i i'm not crazy for that am i
no it's a real offense yeah like it's
west coast terminology i i know i know
mark wiffel's offense i worked with
spencer his son he's with the cardinals
now but yeah i i'm during my time no
that's not crazy at all that's the
appeal of him is that he drops in and he
hears this terminology willis is going
to hear the terminology and it'll be
like right 62. and pick it goes in and
he's used to those 18 word play calls is
that good that they're 18 words that's
another discussion but that is going to
appeal to some teams that he can go in
and rookie mini camp and mini camp and
it's not just a convoluted mess teams
like that teams don't like looking like
they're breaking the huddle and stuff
yeah no i love it so here's the thing
we've talked about the quarterbacks
let's get to top risers the top rogers
we're gonna start with the running backs
and i'm gonna throw out damian pierce uh
this is a guy we've called him a bruiser
before we talked about how physical he
is as a runner i know he didn't lead
florida in rushing yards but when you
look at the tape you see that he runs
through arm tackles he's not afraid to
be violent in between the tackles this
is a guy that instead of cutting out
instead of finding ways to get outside
he keeps winning look in one run he
finds multiple ways to stay inside and i
think that's that that that is reflected
in him putting up 21 on the bench for a
running back that's pretty good numbers
you see him here he can still catch out
of the backfield to be a problem so i
i'm going to go with damian pierce
connor i know you wanted to get to to
south dakota state we're going off the
map a little bit to talk about some
speed
felder i love the pier shout out he from
the film to now the testing and the body
type he is a david montgomery clone but
i do want to take this to a small school
and look at pierre strong jr south
dakota state running back that you turn
on the tape right and you see him just
absolutely he's the fastest player on
the field and that's not going to
surprise you at that level but then when
you go to the combine and you run sub 4
4 you absolutely light up the track at a
4 3 7 40 in a 36 inch vertical jump
you're testing with the big dogs you're
showing that you are an nfl caliber
athlete he's got really good vision he's
got really good burst that's gonna play
at the next level you could be looking
at a team like the dolphins you could be
looking at the classic 49ers trap the
running back on day three every single
year this is a little throwback comp for
you but pierre strong reminds me of
joseph adai who went really early in his
draft this is a player that was probably
looking at a round six or seven
projection if you asked me two months
ago the kind of process he's had he's
looking right at round four right now
nate get in here and talk about bruce
hall
i i love my breeze hall i actually i
called him a poor man's robert smith is
like who i compared him to just that
long breakaway speed but i'm going to
talk about another back this one from
iowa state baris so breese hall as
opposed to pierre strong greece hall is
a patient in between the tackles runner
almost patient to a fault and i think
that's why when he ran the high fourth
people i think a lot of us including
myself thought he run about a little
four or five he's got good size he's a
complete back um a really the comparison
and i think it's almost too easy to make
is almost like a poor man's le'veon bell
in the sense when le'veon was with the
steelers and run behind that patient and
that bruising offensive line being
patient hitting the hole but bruce hall
has enough athleticism he can burst
through it he has to work on his pass
protection like 95 percent of running
backs coming out of college do but he
has good hands when he's coming out of
the backfield wasn't asked to run a lot
of routes but he's a complete has the
potential to be a three down back he has
the size for it has a little tread on
his tires but really he can step in and
start from somebody and just eat 15
touches a game right off the bat because
of just his patience and any run style
that he can be productive in
yeah i i love bruce hall too uh listen i
will say this damian pierce one of the
guys that does not have to work on their
pass pro he's very good at doing it
already real brilliant yes he showed hit
the sneaker bowl uh i want to get to
another top risers these are guys not
running backs but i'm gonna go with alec
pierce al pierce was on my list because
i wanted to see what he ran i wanted to
see what he ran and see what he jumped
so uh let's start with nate connor you
rap you get back to him and then we'll
take it to the next guy but alec pierce
4-4-1
jumps to jumps up 40 and a half come on
baby nate that's crazy
he was a four i was being told former
volleyball player former volleyball
player well he showed that he was a
former volleyball player and i mean
you'll see in these clips coming up it's
just this is what he is he is a jump
ball winner he dunks on guys every game
get vertical he improved as a route
runner throughout this year like a
little bit more polish his releases were
a lot better than you would think uh
he's a little more straight line he's
not great after the catch but man if
you're talking about an intermediate and
deep guy that you can grow into a number
two and really early in his career be a
special teams ace because
cincinnati they thought about putting
that linebacker for a little bit before
switching them back to receiver so he
had
a play to him but just great at high
pointing throws and a great big body for
somebody on a vertical type of offense
would be great and just really that that
speed like you said it's good
with the time speed which is good at
that size
yeah the testing was huge for him
because i think he was someone that kind
of built this narrative around can he
separate at the next level right and i'm
curious to see is you know transitioning
to the nfl i like that you threw out the
special team's ability there nate i
think he's somebody that can get looks
in between the 20s as a big slot target
because of the ball skills that can
translate in the middle of the field
then you get down to the red zone kick
them outside let them get one-on-one
match-ups and win the football in the
air so for alec piers he had a really
good combine he obviously had a strong
senior bowl just getting that invite is
huge for him and he's going to be a back
end of the roster kind of receiver early
on that could fight for more reps by
year two
yeah i'm looking forward to watching him
play he's he's been absolutely fun to
watch and
as we talked about desmond ritter
desmond he's helped desmond ritter a ton
because there are some off-target balls
that alec pierce was able to make turn
into touchdowns so i love that about him
let's go to oklahoma nick benito he runs
a 4-5 at the combine and
for an edge guy who to me and we talked
about him on the last show uh he's
someone that strikes me connor as a guy
who can come in and nate you can get on
the back end of this but connor he
strikes me as someone who can come in be
an early pass rush specialist before he
grows into a role as an every down
player
yeah felder he's got a day one role and
that's called get after the quarterback
on third and long and he's a he's an
impressive stand-up rusher i mean he can
win you see him winning the corner there
he's shown the ability to counter inside
and cross the face of tackles it was
hilarious watching him run with the
defensive tackles for some reason at the
combine i don't know whose idea that was
he ran a 4-5-4 at 250 pounds 6'3 he's
got the length the arm's over 32 inches
so i think for nick bonito you want him
to come into your system and really be
that third down stand-up rusher keep it
simple for him say listen the conversion
to speed to power right there is
something that if he can find
consistency with that and not just be a
finesse rusher but show a just a smidge
of a power rusher he's going to be a
problem on third downs and there are a
lot of teams that put so much value into
these guys that come in the field on
passing downs from day one especially
when teams go to nickel which is almost
base at this point so for nick benito
big time combine and i just love his day
one role that can grow over time as a
three down player
oh no absolutely like that nascar
package that the giants beat the
patriots with back in the day like that
was just that was just like a nice
oddity at the time guess what everybody
has a version of that now and so you
cannot have enough pass rushers you just
can't on your roster and that's what
these types of guys are like if even if
he goes in the early second mid second
okay
only maybe play 12 snaps a game now it's
20 to 30 to 35 because there's more and
more passing downs more spread looks
more light personnel so these guys these
types of guys are only going to have
more and more value it doesn't matter if
oem is undersized it's a dpr guess what
when you're passing about 40 to 50 times
dpr has become they're on the field a
lot more often when you have these pass
rush packages out there
yeah exactly so i want to go i want to
go travis jones right this is the guy
from uconn uh let me make sure i get the
numbers right i gotta check my board out
4 9
at 3 25
4 9 at 3 25 and i know we all were
celebrating jordan davis and his ability
to to get it moving but
connor travis jones baby
i mean felder we're almost in round one
territory right now with travis jones
especially in this class and you see it
on the lower there round two post
combine might sneak into the back end of
round one
he kind of got this false narrative from
his season that he's this two gapping
run stuffing nose tackle because of his
size and he was on a bad team which
didn't help a lot he goes down to the
senior ball and he's throwing these
haymakers and pass pass rush drills that
shows he can be this three down player
and if jordan davis didn't have this
combine from outer space
people would notice that travis jones at
325 like you said ran that 4-9-2 that is
freakish even the 7-3-3 3-cone drill at
that size there are not a lot of people
on planet earth at that weight can move
like that but also play with the power
so for travis jones three down nose
tackle i don't even think we're at the
point where he's scheme specific because
of the overall ability against the run
and against the pass he's just had a
great two months here after an
impressive season on tape
yeah all right let's biggest losers the
biggest losers of the jordan davis
workout are anybody that wanted jordan
davis in the 20s and travis jones those
are the two biggest losers of jordan
davis's
i workout he was it was phenomenal what
he was able to do was insane and i'm
glad that you mentioned it there's not a
lot of people on the planet that are
that big that can move that well uh
connor you want to take us to the
comments
yeah let's dive into the comments here
before we keep this moving along uh nate
i'll throw this first one to you from
jr8 who said is drake london worth the
hype do you think he's an nfl guy i
think we can we can take away the second
part of that question we know drake
london is going to play at the nfl level
the question is coming off the injury he
couldn't work out at the combine
everyone in the world is wondering what
he's gonna run but do you think drake
london is worth the hype right now
yeah i i love drake london i really do
big fan uh i love his size he has more
uh receiver to him than i originally
thought thought he was just gonna be a
big former basketball player ball winner
he actually plays with some toughness in
his game like he's a willing blocker he
throws tacklers off you can see on these
clips him just high pointing balls of
course he can do that as a former
basketball player but really he has more
route runner to him he has the
athleticism to sink he can line up
inside and out and i just think he's one
of those guys i am super super high on
yes he i his long speed is an ideal as
an elite i still think it's okay i think
he's more of a mid like a four five six
type of guy which i'd be fine with at
that size um i really really like him i
think he's a true ex and that
true true mismatch type in the nfl which
is when you're taking a guy in the
lottery that's the type of guy you want
you don't want the guy that oh man it's
a physical corner they can get taken out
you want the big boys
yeah i i like his size i love that he's
nimble he for someone that big he
shouldn't be that nimble and there's a
quickness and suddenness to his game
that i truly appreciate and the biggest
thing for me and i'm glad you mentioned
kind of a basketball background he is
someone that plays to his height and
taller
and we see a lot of guys who are 6'3
that play five eight and he is someone
that is what he's six three six four but
he plays like he's six eight and i love
that about his game he's able to high
point the same thing goes with alec
pierce so if you're asking me yes he's
an nfl player and is he worth the risk i
think absolutely maybe it's not in your
first round but certainly on the second
day when you can get a guy who's not
afraid to go up and and and go get the
football and i will say this i also love
that he played
in a in a wide receivers room with a guy
like amman ross st brown because saint
brown is a dog and getting to watch him
in person just from high school going
into college i think that he brought a
lot of that mentality to the rest of
that group and i think all those guys
adopted a lot of that
anger that he plays yeah
saint brown didn't act like a five star
i think that was the biggest compliment
i ever gave him was he didn't play like
a five star and i met that as a
compliment because he was willing to do
the dirty work i'm happy he had a
breakout rookie year because he's such a
fun player as well
all right felder here's one for you
before you take us to our next segment
eagles webster asked who is the best
forgotten prospect the one without any
hype that's going to play 10 to 11 years
and be great in the nfl
i mean connor you know my answer to this
one it's jamar's i know that's why i
saved this question for you
i love jamari sawyer yes from georgia
plays left tackle can play guard he can
do whatever you want him to do he's
gonna be in the league for a decade
you're gonna and then when he retires
that's when your team's gonna realize
oh we had it really really good and i
think that's the part that's interesting
and like i don't care about his tests i
don't care about anything like honestly
this is a great segue into our next
segment which is just watch the film
because if you just watch the film on
jamar's song you're going to see a guy
that's a true football player so let's
get to just watch the film because i
think we've got a couple guys in here
connor i'll start with you
kyron williams this is a guy didn't run
as well as he wanted right 4-6
4-6-5 didn't run as well as he wanted to
but
you watch the film
and he's a good running back this guy's
super athletic and there's a suddenness
and a quickness that he brings to the
table just watch the film
i mean just watch it this guy can play
on all three downs and he could do it
right now and you heard nate say earlier
on the show about 95 percent of these
young running backs need to work on pass
pro that's spot on and it's a lot of the
top guys in this class whether it's
bruce hall kenneth walker a lot of them
do kyron williams does not he takes
pride in it and he's got that short area
change of direction and contact balance
as a runner that can turn zero yards
into four that can turn four yards into
nine these are the things that are not
flashy these are the things that do not
win you fantasy football trophies but
they win you they win you real football
games that's what kyron williams does so
i look at him i mean we kind of went
through this process last year michael
carter was an undersized back that did
not test well at a small size and then
everybody sat there and said wow i
really liked him every saturday for two
years and then he got to the draft and
he didn't hear his name called till
round four nbn ended up being one of the
better picks the new york jets have had
in a while and ended up being an impact
player kyron williams not going to go
round one he's not going to go round two
i don't think he even goes round three
but somebody will take him on round four
and he will play he will play a lot as a
rookie and he can contribute on any down
just watch the film i
i love it just watch the film jake
ferguson uh nate you get in here first
on jake ferguson come on man this guy is
i mean i get it four one eight four
eight one excuse me he's running four
one eight we'll be talking about him in
a different way but he ran a 4-8-1 and
but you watch when you watch ferguson
play
is there a play that he can't make he's
so good
yeah he's a true wide tight end it's a
guy that can play all three downs and
has like not just blocking wise and all
that but he plays faster than the 4-8 i
was actually stunned by that time but
he's a tough complete tight end
oh they play for 10 years and they'll be
great i think ferguson's a guy that
plays for 10 years and he's solid he's
one of those guys he's just useful um
has enough athleticism that he can run
those intermediate like you can even see
on this catching these over
immediate type routes that he might be
asked to run on passing down second
along and third down he's not just a
check down guy he's got good hands tough
he uses his hands on the run game like
he's a real good blocker already and
that's the thing too it's uh you may
even talk about kyron williams with his
blocking uh tying it in with the
tonguing with the wisconsin ties karen
williams is james white to me like i
mean i just one for one useful in real
life great pass protection guy great uh
receiver and same with jake ferguson
these are useful players is he as sexy
as maybe
kyle pitts last year running a 4-4 at 20
years old or whatever he was you know no
but these guys play a lot of ball
because they can do so much they don't
have to come off the field
dalton schultz type that they can just
do everything well you never have to
hide them everything you ask them to do
they just do well and i think that's
what jake ferguson could be for somebody
yeah he like i've said this before he's
he's like a heath miller tight end like
a guy that just every game he shows up
he's there and then i mentioned it with
sawyer but i'll mention it with ferguson
i think he's someone that's going to
play on your team for 10 years he's he's
going to be great in the community doing
a bunch of extra stuff every kid's going
to love him and then when he retires
you're going to be like oh man it is
hard to find a good tight end uh last
guy i'm going to go to and i want to get
both of you guys thoughts on this connor
we'll start with you george carlactis
this is a guy he came in as a five-star
producer i believe highest recruit that
they've ever had he is someone who is
we've seen him be strong we've seen him
transition speed to power we've watched
him
accumulate those tackles for loss we've
watched him get to the quarterback
obviously he played it purdue so he
wasn't playing it he's not saying he's
playing at ohio state he didn't really
have somebody else on the other side all
the time when he was playing so when you
look at carlatus and a guy that his
numbers were okay but his numbers
weren't mind-blowing what do you think
conor and then nate you drop in before
we get to before conor takes us to the
comments um connor what do you think
about carlatus
well you can come in and he can play all
three downs for you and you have to love
that with a young player and i think
carloptis is so strong at the point of
attack
that coaches will feel comfortable
having him in the field on early downs
and then they know the power that he
converts as a rusher should transition
at the next level now what you want to
see from carloftus or what a lot of
scouts want to see is run that 40 run
the three cone how is the change of
direction he didn't do it at the combine
we'll see what the pro day brings and
honestly felder i think he's just a
player that has been hurt not by what
he's done but the astronomical rise of
jermaine johnson and david jabbo this
year karloftis was always the guy after
aiden hutchinson and kayvon thibodeaux
and now he's kind of been passed in a
lot of that by jermaine johnson
and obviously at jabo again so probably
looking at the back end or maybe middle
of round one for carloftus not the top
ten but it'll be very productive early
on
yeah and i i think coral office is that
he would get better throughout each game
like he it always seemed like he never
really had a plan like a pass rush plan
and it seemed to me like as those games
would go along he would like the second
half film would be so much better than
the first half film it's one of those
guys that grows on you i was shocked he
had longer arms than hutchinson did
that is uh that was that's an upset of
upsets i think from the combine
measurements was that that right there
not 40 times just long arms uh longer
arms and hutches
yeah i think he ends up being a very
good number two for somebody but i think
that's what you said conor is that like
yeah it's somebody that he's other guys
have gotten a little sexier than what he
is right now i think we kind of all are
of agreement what george caller office
is right now
i don't connor i know you got to take us
to the comments but we have one more guy
in here traelyn burks
uh
ran the 4-5 we er the first show we said
i said i think he's probably gonna run a
four five eight you guessed four four i
will say listen this is me patting
myself on the back
but here's
but
if you watch the tape it doesn't matter
how fast he runs because he's fast
enough to get away from people
that's it felder i mean he also plays at
225 pounds so it's exciting that calvin
austin who's
literally like trailing burks's left leg
ran in the four threes that's all good
and fun but traelyn burks plays at the
size of a lot of nfl linebackers right
now and it's it's build up speed right
it's the 20 yards to the 40 yards not
the zero to 10 and that does matter it's
important but it's also valuable so i
think when you look at trailing burks
you don't want to get crazy and start
moving him a different round right
because he's someone on the outside that
can win vertically he's someone with
scheme touches that can make things
happen after the catch and he's somebody
that's going to come into your system at
that size and he's going to block
cornerbacks and safeties and he's going
to take a lot of pride in it so for
trailing burks i don't think he's
drafted over garrett wilson jameson
williams it's going to be very
interesting how teams break him and
drake london down but i still love the
player because the tape in my opinion is
right up there with any wide receiver in
this class
yeah he's a
fun player to watch
take us to the comments man let's go
yeah let's jump into it right here as uh
we are rolling right now i'll throw this
to both of you guys nate and then felder
brennan said what is the deepest
position in this class is any position
going to have starters after round two
oh yeah um i think i think one of the
deepest i really think d-line is pretty
deep um i i mean just uh my glance top
my head i think that's a position you
can find a lot of guys and just a lot of
useful guys it might not have that bendy
those guys that we think is the sexy
picks but a lot of those kind of like
run plugging types there's different
types of nose or no interior tackles
there's a couple projects you can look
at but really i think i think defensive
line is one of the in the second round
especially and even in going into the
third i think teams are gonna find some
real real guys the other one would be
receivers i think this receiver class is
loaded i think right now on our big
board for police report i have 18 guys
with a top 100 grade our first three
round grade which is ridiculous and i'm
a tough grader on receivers um so i
think i think receiver and defense align
no i i agree with that i think defensive
tackle it's a super stout defensive
tackle draft obviously at the top and
then you get to the middle you're still
gonna find guys are gonna end up
figuring it out in the nfl a little bit
better and then the other one i was
gonna say
because of the way that we play college
football now wide receiver is going to
be on this list forever
because there's always going to be guys
who are catching anywhere from 55 to 100
balls a year and just have the reps in
the polish to get the job done and
so receiver is always going to be on the
list and
i will say this i do think that running
back fits in there as well especially
with the way that we value running backs
now or devalue running backs it's always
going to be something that's super meaty
in the middle of the year i mean we
haven't even talked about sincere
mccormick uh yet this show uh so i'll
bring him up because i think we're gonna
have to just bring him up every single
show connor but we haven't seen mccoy
this guy's a dude he's a dude like
you're gonna be able to get him
on what early day three you can get a
sincere mccormick and he can do
everything oh yeah this is a guy that
wants to run between the tackles he
realizes this is something i don't think
nearly enough running backs realize the
fastest way to get to the end zone is a
straight line and he takes it all the
time
it's physical yeah i mean i you know i'm
with you all the way felder he is
someone that can come in and just be
your pass catching back and he's got
some explosive plays all right going to
read a comment and then felder take us
to the biggest movers this one though is
for you la aqua said shout out to the
og's that remember heath miller hashtag
throwback
yo listen my dad's a steelers fan man
like i
my dad grew up in germany and they only
got two football games a week and it was
cowboys and steelers so
loves the cowboys hates the steeler
excuse me loves the steelers hates the
cowboys so i watched a lot of steelers
football and that includes heath miller
not to mention i played at unc heath
miller played at virginia so yeah this
dude is heath miller one of those gold
standard guys from a position standpoint
as you watch our just watched the film
we've got williams we've got ferguson
we've got karlatas we've got trail and
burks uh we also got some big movers we
got a couple guys that we want to put
into the big movers category uh guys
that
quite honestly one i know that connor's
in love with the other one i wasn't sure
how i felt about him and then i saw the
numbers and i was like oh this is um
terrifying for what he might be able to
do at the next level so i'm gonna kick
it off with louis c
and
oh my goodness i i he's a guy that i
always thought was good coming down into
the box
he's a guy that i thought was fine in
coverage horizontally
wasn't sure if he had the speed to take
to carry vertically
but when you run what are you what are
we looking at here four three seven four
three four seven
at six three
nate
this dude's a killer
did you guys know the georgia defense
was good last year
i mean
where do they feed these guys i mean but
that that's exactly it i thought the
same thing as you felt it was that i
wasn't sure how this guy would actually
move and guess what he moves very very
very well uh but he's going to come in
the league he's going to be smart he's
asked to run a complicated defense which
only helps these guys so now you're
getting an athlete that's played big
gains that's played in a a more
complicated defense that's the type of
guy that's going to appeal to teams
because i'm sure he did great on the
board as well just playing in that
defense in the kirby smart defense um so
i i mean
you get a guy like that and also they
test well it's the opposite of wisconsin
i think a lot of wisconsin guys lose
their shine because also they run the
40. i think these georgia guys they see
how smart and fast that they play and
also they truly test well it's like why
not but i think he made himself a lot of
money because he's going to appeal to a
lot of teams
yeah i mean just freakish stuff right
that broad jump coming in at 133 that's
that's 96 percentile like he's in rare
territory and that's not factoring the
size so when you're talking about a big
safety with length carries weight plays
violent and then tests like an elite
athlete at the position this is pretty
rare stuff i think we're looking at
louisiana if not in round one that
classic popular guy that when we go into
day two every team is trying to get to
pick 33 to 40 to get him he's just that
valuable i love kyle hamilton there's no
doubt he's a great player but when you
look at the second tier of the safety
class in the top round two lewis seen
dax hill incredible combine and jaquan
brisker and that's not even getting into
jaylen petrie those guys are all
starters and now we're talking about
they might be high-end starters by year
two or three
hey don't forget about my guy brian cook
from cincinnati baby i love it right so
i got to throw him in there
as i like
but man connor like i'm just i just
we're thinking about lewiston coming
downhill and just stoning a running back
and i'm like that's
okay i guess that is what a 437 looks
like when you come running out of the
deep middle to hit a guy at seven yards
and blow him up um
we got a quote here right don't we have
a quote from from connor's guide
jermaine johnson if we can get that
quote up i'm gonna read it because he
came in with confidence
and here it is from jermaine johnson
florida state a defensive end because i
do everything exceptionally well i play
the run as well as i play the pass
nobody in this class does what does that
like i do when he said that he's the
best defense he's the best edge the best
defensive end in this class
connor the confidence the confidence
match the numbers man this guy's good
oh he's he's better than good felder
he's great and this was you know when
you get to the combine all these players
speak this was the only podium i stayed
from the second he arrived to the second
he left because it's a humble confidence
he's had a long road from juco to
georgia to florida state to now being
one of the stars of this draft and he
just takes so much pride in being a
three down player the effort and violent
approach he has on the field that one
five five ten yard split is elite rare
territory that is your how am i getting
off the ball and the burst and that is
going to impact at the next at the next
level so for jermaine johnson you know
the one thing i wanted to ask him and i
did get to ask him i was like where do
you like rushing from because we've seen
you win inside we've seen you win
outside and he said when i got to
florida state there was a plan for me to
rush off the outside shoulder of the
tackle he's like i also like rushing
from the wide nine i just want to pin my
ears back from the outside and get after
the quarterback and it's all there on
film the production uh that temperament
he's a special player i don't think the
top five is out of range for him at this
point draft
what i had heard too is that he he is uh
spicy huh what what i had heard too is
that like people that are watching my
georgia said that like oh yeah him
playing to run at georgia was not like
this and from what i've gathered is they
challenged him they said hey like we
want you to be a better run player and
guess what that's like his elite trait
now so not only did he improve he made
he went from average to elite at it
excellent at it and that's really cool
to see and then he tests well and it's
like well if you're a hard worker and
you're athletic that's a pretty
good take take a bet on him in the
lottery
yeah i think that's all there i'm glad
felder before we get to the comments i
got one more thing i got another guy
because i've people i've seen people
kind of like oh i need to revisit this
guy i haven't watched enough of this guy
but it's a guy that ran a 461
but he's also six foot seven 260 pounds
jelani woods from virginia i had to
throw him in i know he's not in the dock
but i had to throw him in there because
this dude he's like
like there's a bunch of big football
players
but there's not guys that would look
normal on an nba court and he is one of
those guys so
connor to nate and connor you take us to
the comments after but jelani woods like
he helped himself right
yeah he's built like a power forward
felder i mean he really is but he's in
football pads so that's absolutely
terrifying and when you see that coming
up the seam i don't know what you do if
you're a linebacker how do you run with
them if you're a safety or a corner do
you want to come down and run into that
brick wall that power forward i don't
know and no you don't you know you felt
it you know first hand so i think when
you look at it with woods
he
slowly got better throughout college
long road obviously a transfer had a big
breakout has had a really good combine i
think that athleticism is so big for him
as teams love these project tight ends
not a guy that they're going to put at
the y and say you're you know you're
playing 80 of the snaps right away but
we know there's certain intermediate
passing situations where we're going to
see you grow and develop and teams are
just loving that with him right now in a
deep tight end class
no absolutely he he had a great shrine
week and then when you watch him on film
and the great testing of course with
the combine it's that
you see him run down the seam and just
box out guys and
just box out high point and just meander
into the end zone and it's great he had
he's of all the tight ends he's had the
one the best kind of spring to really
launch himself really probably a full
round or two i originally had a low
fourth on him but seeing him testing him
at the shrine week i i bumped him up a
full round i think he's like late thirds
middle third because he's a wide tight
end that can do enough in the red zone
and i'm passing down so you can find use
for him on passing downs as well
all right before we get out of here want
to dive back into the comments one more
time apparently we went down real quick
we have mcat 93 said we crash
let's go
draft crash course crash course for a
reason
all right
nate i'm gonna throw this one to you
because i know you've been very wide
receiver heavy in the scouting uh for
bleacher reports so far tommy rossi 78
says who is the best wide receiver in
this class
my receiver one is drink london actually
and that's what's funny there you go uh
my top two i have drake one and one and
crystal lava at two and they couldn't be
any more different flavors uh which is
fun uh i think those are my top top two
guys but we've already i already got my
gush in about drake london uh like we
said there's more football player to him
with that excellent size and that
basketball background and brings that
toughness and i felt a very great point
about how st brown really brought that
room to like really embrace that side of
football um i would say real real quick
talking about chris alave i think he's
one of the most scheme-proof guys of any
position in this draft i think that guy
can plop and play and be somebody's
number two without a doubt and with the
upside of being a true number one target
monster um i think
lobby i love him i think we just got
bored of him um i think that's really
what happened thankfully he tested well
and it's like seeing a movie you haven't
seen in 10 years and going like oh yeah
that movie's pretty good
i think that's kind of what we did with
crystal lava a little bit but those are
my top two and i i this is a great class
six guys with first round grades i have
right now but those are my my favorite
two because i think they can really be
useful right away and have the ability
to have that ceiling to really read that
reach that very good elite level
all right before we get out of here
felder you always have a
round three round four round five guy
for me is there someone in this wide
receiver class that's not in that a
lobby london berks garrett wilson kind
of molds but you're looking at them and
going there's either a roll which we
love to talk about on this show or
people are just straight up missing them
here's the thing i i actually was geared
up loaded up right here to talk about
jamison williams
because he's due
i think he's the best
in this group i think that and obviously
people are going to talk about him
transfer from ohio state and garrett
wilson versus larvae versus ham and him
kind of having to leave to find his way
but i just think that
there is something i i i i'm gonna i'm
gonna eschew the late guy to go with
jamison williams simply because i think
that
he deserve he's been
so far off people's radar that it's
almost like like like what is it like
they like forgot about dre like that's
what he feels like like
it's it's it's it's a bunch of gibberish
but people act like they forgot about
about jamison williams like this dude is
the truth
he's a great route runner there is a
stick your foot in the ground to get up
field that he has that a lot of guys
don't understand he also has the ability
to buy himself time on the sideline that
other people don't do and i guess if
you're gonna go you know what i'll pick
his teammate for what you're talking
about right as that second third maybe i
love it there's a third i'm gonna go met
you i'll go met you because he is
someone who guess what
he understands where he's supposed to be
on the field
and
nate can you chime in on this like wide
receivers understanding where they're
supposed to be on the field is
incredibly important
yeah and that's when you watch a guy
it's yes we we go
amazing this guy's great but then when
you watch a guy play after play after
play and see the times they're not
getting the ball and how they affect the
other route concepts that are happening
but that's the thing why i love about
jameson williams i thought i was going
in i was like all right this guy's gonna
be a speed threat with some double moves
whatever and then you watch him it's
like dude this dude can run routes he
knows how to tempo his stuff like he
knows how to like threaten the guy and
then throttle down and stay safe to the
quarterback and i was like okay i i'm a
big fan of james williams i'm so glad
you brought him up and the same with
john metchi is that
i think that's what mechi has lost some
appeal because he didn't he hasn't had
the freakish testing or splash plays
that maybe some of these other guys have
but he's solid and there's so there's
used to that like you're saying being
reliable and being finding space always
going to the right spot and being that
nice underneath option for somebody my
day two day three guy i want to bring up
is khalil shakir from boise state i i'm
a huge huge huge fan of him
i i'm a huge fan i think that guy's a
baller and i uh inside it out legit
route runner great after the catch has
returned a bit
you can't good hands i'm a big fan of
khalil shakira though
felder you're about to jump out of your
shoes please speak like
he knows where he's supposed to be and
that's the thing like i don't think
people think about this like it's great
i understand it's fantastic and we watch
these wide receivers that are burners
and a guy can run a a 4-2 or whatever
but nobody runs routes full speed you're
not supposed to run routes full speed
right you're supposed to tempo them as
you mentioned nate so that you lull
someone into something so that then you
can use your burst to get away from them
and
shakir he does all those things like i
loved watching him i think he was the
best thing to happen to hank bachmaire
because it allowed bachmaire to realize
oh this is what a wide receiver is
supposed to do this is what the game is
supposed to look like and it's so
yeah i'm so glad you brought him up the
kid is good he's so good and then
obviously we've already mentioned alex
pierce but this is that's a great point
i hope folks take that away from this
where we start looking not just at
did he go 10 yards and then bend it in
did he rip off a hard edge did he but i
like i'm look when i watch wide
receivers i look at guys that give up
too much ground to the outside guys that
give up too much space wide guys that
that fade instead of bend and all those
little things those all matter and so i
think shakira's a great one i think
mechy again is another good one and i
think understanding i'm glad you
mentioned this too
understanding where you fit in a route
concept because even if you're not going
to get the football i do need you
to take this safety out of the way
so that i can get the guy behind you i
can get the guy behind him and i think
uh all those guys we mentioned have that
ability so yeah i'm you can see this is
something that gets me jazzed up because
as a defensive back when i watch a guy
that knows what he's doing it it drives
me i'm like no
this shouldn't be fair because now
there's nothing we can do about this
he's just gonna make a play and i'm sure
for you as a quarterback it's like
but if you just did the thing the right
way we could have had a first down
yep
as you can see here guys
go ahead nate we're like both both so
animated about this once you realize the
drop back and the protection and the
routes all tie in together and then you
start seeing oh this guy's short on
every route and he's screwing yeah he's
great with the ball in his hands but
he's screwing up everything else that's
when you like you start to appreciate
the guys that have those little details
to them i always say rap details and
that's just my catch-all for it all but
yeah that's what that's why i love
shakira and mechi as well
i'll close the wide receiver
conversation with this on sportsbooks
i've seen jameson williams as plus 800
as the first wide receiver to come off
the board
that is shocking value i think he will
be the first wide receiver taken in this
draft and i've heard a lot of buzz about
the same so
you know what to do after this show we'd
love to be here all day but we'll have
to wait till next week next thursday 1
p.m eastern time it is draft crash
course i'm connor rogers for michael
felder and for nate tys thanks so much
for being with us this week we'll catch
you next thursday
[Music]
[Music]
you